[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france 24 mi nombre es álvaro cordero
este 15 de agosto se cumple el primer
aniversario de la toma de kabul por
parte de los talibanes una fecha marcada
por la precipitada salida de las tropas
occidentales y por lo que significó la
vuelta al poder de los talibanes en
afganistán tras 20 años de guerra en
france 24 repasamos la historia de este
grupo fundamentalista sus orígenes y el
desarrollo que ha tenido cuando estuvo
en el poder y fuera de él
la formación de los talibanes se remonta
al año 1994 para esa época afganistán
vivía un periodo muy inestable en el que
la nación centroasiática estaba dominada
por señores de la guerra que competían
entre sí una consecuencia directa de la
invasión y la guerra librada entre 1979
y 1989 contra la unión soviética este
conflicto había hecho fuertes a unos
combatientes con un marcado carácter
religioso llamados muy ágiles y es a
partir de algunos de ellos donde surgen
los talibanes
desde kabul los talibanes proclamaron el
emirato islámico de afganistán un
régimen que pronto atraería la mirada
internacional
durante su gobierno se aplicaron duros
castigos por violar dogmas religiosos y
morales que iban desde los azotes o las
amputaciones a ejecuciones masivas en
público además el papel de las mujeres
afganas quedó totalmente relegado
haciendo que dependan enteramente de los
hombres y reduciendo casi totalmente sus
libertades
bajo el gobierno del mulá omar un
misterioso líder religioso y militar que
encabezó a los talibanes durante años se
dio cobijo a osama bin laden y su
formación al qaeda algo que puso en la
mira de la comunidad internacional
afganistán especialmente tras los
ataques terroristas a las torres gemelas
de nueva york y al pentágono el 11 de
septiembre de 2001 un golpe que hizo
reaccionar a eeuu que dio un ultimátum a
los talibanes para entregar a bin laden
pero la respuesta fue negativa haciendo
que el 7 de octubre de 2001 eeuu
decidiera invadir junto a sus aliados
afganistán para derrocar a los talibanes
y capturar a osama bin laden y a la
cúpula de al qaeda la superioridad
inicial era total y por medio de
bombardeos fueron arrinconando a las
tropas talibanes
queremos luchar contra los
estadounidenses sobre el terreno el
pueblo de afganistán está listo nos
estamos reuniendo con los talibanes
queremos luchar contra los
estadounidenses desde la tierra no en el
cielo en de skype en apenas dos meses el
poder talibán colapsó y la mayoría de
sus militantes fueron asesinados o
tuvieron que huir a zonas remotas o
incluso a pakistán para poder sobrevivir
aunque no se logró capturar ni al líder
talibán ni a osama bin laden
gracias a nuestro ejército nuestros
aliados y a los valientes combatientes
de afganistán el régimen talibán está
llegando a su fin
físicamente
desde ese momento el conflicto se
convirtió en una guerra lenta el poder
talibán aunque residual en un inicio fue
aumentando poco a poco y minando a las
fuerzas occidentales que siguieron
teniendo presencia los ataques pasaron a
ser diarios y la preocupación aumentó la
crisis de violencia hizo que durante el
gobierno de obama las tropas desplegadas
aumentaran hasta las 110 mil en 2011 una
inversión de cientos de miles de
millones de dólares que sin embargo no
sirvió para mejorar la situación del
país por lo que a partir de 2014 eeuu
empezó a retirar tropas con el objetivo
de formar al ejército afgano y marcharse
para muchos de ustedes esta será su
última misión en afganistán y para
finales de año la transición estará
completa y los afganos asumirán la
responsabilidad total de su seguridad y
nuestra misión de combate habrá
terminado
con la guerra de estados unidos en
afganistán llegará a un final
responsable
[Música]
una decisión que tuvo consecuencias ya
que durante los siguientes años los
talibanes consiguieron reconfigurarse y
aumentar su poderío militar
la cuestión afgana se convirtió en un
gran problema para los eeuu algo que
facilitaría que durante el gobierno de
donald trump se dieran las negociaciones
para sacar a las tropas restantes de
afganistán un diálogo que dio sus frutos
el 29 de febrero de 2020 el objetivo era
traer la paz al país centroasiático pero
aunque eeuu firmó un acuerdo el gobierno
afgano nunca logró pactar nada con los
talibanes algo que comprometía su futuro
tras la salida de trump del poder la
administración baiden heredó lo acordado
y se propuso salir el 30 de agosto de
2021 sin embargo los acontecimientos se
precipitaron en julio y agosto de 2021
aunque el gobierno estadounidense
pensaba que el ejército afgano
resistiría en cuestión de días varias
ciudades fueron cayendo al poder talibán
y el 15 de agosto lo hizo kabul la
desordenada salida de eeuu de la capital
afgana generó momentos de caos y dio una
imagen mala ante la comunidad
internacional el punto final
controversial a una de las guerras más
costosas de la historia que tras 20 años
terminó como empezó con los talibanes en
el poder con esto concluimos gracias por
compartir y comentar estas historias que
las encuentran en los programas de
france 24 punto com
[Música]